yeah welcome to this video late start
let's see you have stopped it with one
ear for now let's see what I'm going to
do your night f60 that's a bit more
looks like somewhat stranger combination
of the the modern and the Alec I'd 94
okay his son on Bishop d3 is going to
play the fire fried hmm yeah some way to
to play against that idea maybe seaforth
Bishop d3 trying to make it harder for
him to play d5 okay if I now go hmm
Bishop d3
queen bee three what about that I see
six year okay maybe just special d3
trying to play against the night yeah
now I'm going to take the night is
hanging now Bishop f5 this g4 and here
play Queenie to what is you move now
Bishop f5 there's g4 I think and f5 look
sir yeah like it saves the piece for the
moment but otherwise it's terrible maybe
Bishop f5 can be played with some sort
of tactic in mind but I don't really see
it at the moment still that's just g4 I
believe yeah let's think about it for a
moment g4 is there some sort of
discovery night somewhere not really it
looks a bit shaky because of this
diagonal the d5 h1 diagonal but I don't
really see what the problem is also one
issue is after I take on f5 there is
still this issue of their of the night
yes I'm bishop see to wear guess here
okay maybe you then that's not really on
night discovery night g3 takes bishop
see to but I've got Knight c3 this shot
them should settle the deal I don't
really see what its movers knight c6
here i'm going to take f 594 Bishop
takes you four and that's it I only see
knight c6 year to try to attack deform
and then I'll just take night yeah but I
can take with the bishop and then I'm to
Bishop c 2 i've got 93 until that that
should be really the end of end of
things he has no move now Bishop hangs
and Quincy six there is d 5
yeah I don't really think this should be
in any way playable this Knight f6 94
maybe that was just some sort of yeah
most slip type of thing happening now
there's no move really Queenie 6 Quincy
to Quincy for Queenie form and
everything is coordinated
now come on don't tell me you're letting
the clock run down now it's definitely
too late now for any for any saving
operations black resigns yeah I really
don't think that this is Pleyel I mean
maybe while 95 it looks like a somewhat
weird version of vanilla cone not too
young maybe even this this this this
slider the hunt variation I think it's
called like that it's um it's viable now
as he's committed to g6 something like
that could be a could be interesting now
difficult for black here to untangle
okay went to e4 yeah yeah now that's I
mean Bishop d3 is also not bad he will
play d5 i guess and then see form the
problem is that this night is nicely
placed but whenever i get to move this
piece and there's a thread f3 which is
not happening immediately but it could
be yeah well i decided to go see for to
be better equipped for his 35 move the
computer now wants to play a c5 okay the
idea is to play Queen a 5k and then
exchange yes okay you can play that but
what kind of position is that white is
just massively better here with the
center I came
so you went d4f and why I played here
yeah maybe he should place his six now
trying to to bolster the center this is
probably not not working yeah here why
does just winning a piece already
according to the comp night f2 is the
relatively best defense according to the
engine but I don't really get it at the
moment why is this should be in any way
playable completion computer wants to go
Bishop c4 here which makes some sense
but if i take it is it so much of a
problem yeah I this also should win but
of course one in a blitz game mad king
is very open so this is probably what
you should have tried this sim this is
just not working i mean i can t also
take it but this is easy i think yeah
and here he he resigned yeah this was a
bit of too much creativity in the
opening i guess you should just play the
normal stuff you like d 6 or or maybe c6
is also possible alright thanks for
watching